hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
today I'm at CES 2013 and we're here
with the Sony Xperia Z or as some of you
might say the sperry is said it's one of
the better-looking phones I've seen here
at CES 2013 and it's got a lot of design
features that a lot of other phones
aren't using so I'll go ahead and show
you these right now first of all it has
a pretty thin bezel and it's also a
relatively thin phone overall it's only
a few millimeters thin and I'll show you
guys the side profile shot right here
it's got a twenty four hundred million
power battery and that's bigger than
that in the galaxy s3 so it's clearly a
strong phone it's got the Qualcomm
Snapdragon s4 pro inside so it's a fast
phone and it's overall I've got a 13
megapixel camera 1080p 5-inch display
it's a high-end display high-end phone
so it's definitely something to consider
if you're looking at other phones like
the galaxy s3 the Droid DNA it's a
little bit smaller than that of the
galaxy note 2 but like we said 5-inch
display
it's definitely pocketable there's not a
big bezel and so like I said it's one my
favorites looks really good the phone is
also water resistant for up to one meter
deep not waterproof but definitely
useful if you happen to splash your
phone it's a durable device and it also
looks really really good having it in
hand and using in person definitely
verifies that I've never been a big Sony
smartphone person but they really
stepped up their game here big-time not
only with the specs but with the skin
they have here it's a new skin doesn't
really have an official name yet but
it's not all that crazy and outlandish
like some other skins we've seen here
Wow way this one still feels smooth and
fast enough though and there are some
useful customizations here so that's
nice now this guy has been making rounds
as potentially the best phone at CES
2013 you can leave a thumbs up if you
agree I actually do kind of agree this
isn't just because of the skin but
because of the build on the internals
this is an exceptionally handsome phone
I think on par with the Nexus 4 it just
looks good it's a thin phone while still
not having a it still actually has a
huge battery it's lightweight not too
light to feel cheap but it is light
enough to be very pocketable now this
unit here also I checked has thirteen
point three gigs of available storage so
I feel like this is a 16 gig phone and
even though they do have to seal it to
make it water resistant you can pull
back a flap and throw
an SD card if you want so that's nice to
have that option it also has NFC has a
quad-core processor and it's been being
demoed with this pair of headphones
where you can just touch it with NFC to
the headphones and control the song and
the track you're playing it might look
weird in public to touch your phone your
headphones but a another possibility the
other gripes I have with this build is
definitely the volume rocker it's in a
weird place below the power button on
the right hand side it should totally be
on the left side also it's a fingerprint
magnet on the back it's definitely a
very fingerprint II pretty easily
because it's so velocity but other than
that it is an awesome device looks
really great and on top of all that it
has top-notch specs which you can view
down in the description below this video
as we know not all five inch displays
are created equal some of them are 1280
by 720 some of them are 1920 by 1080
this one's a 1080p display like I said
but it doesn't have the best viewing
angles in the world just from my
experience with it but it looks pretty
good and it's a Sony Xperia Z that's it
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace